hi there
my name is dr nicole navroski
and today i'm here to speak to you about
forensic science education
in the covit era and i'm going to
discuss the challenges
victories and a novel pedagogical
approach for the future
that we've implemented at the university
of toronto
and i'd love to hear about how you've
implemented
said measures at your institutions or
organizations
as well
so just to get started i want to talk a
little bit about the forensic science
program
at the university of toronto so the
university
of toronto is a tri-campus system we
have the st
george campus which is housed in
downtown toronto
the scarborough campus which is a
remote campus in the scarborough area so
on the east end
of the general toronto area
and then we have the mississauga campus
which is on the west end of the gta
and these three campuses all comprise
a tri-campus system of the university of
toronto
where we have over 50 000 undergraduates
over 10 000 faculty
and thousands of staff support staff
other
coming and going students a large
graduate student body et cetera
so the university of toronto is an
extremely large
academic institution within canada and
has been around for quite some time with
regard to the forensic science program
in particular
we are the oldest program in canada
which is something to be quite proud of
and our faculty is quite diverse in
terms of composition
so we have both traditional forensic
bench scientists
we have traditional bench scientists
that don't specialize
in the forensic sciences so biologists
chemists etc that complement our program
we partner with law enforcement and we
have law enforcement as part of our
faculty
we also bring in and staff legal and
civil professionals
that cross all of the disciplines within
the forensic sciences
so our program is quite unique in terms
of its composition in terms of who
we have at both the undergraduate and
graduate level
teaching as well as the diversity of
programs and courses that we can offer
our students
with this there are inherent challenges
trying to accommodate
busy work schedules trying to
accommodate those who are still
actively working in the field of
forensic science and
supplementing their lives with
additional teaching responsibilities
so what's really great about the
forensic science program is that we have
both
day and night courses and we can cater
to
at times those part-time students who
are trying to
fulfill that forensic science degree
dream
by offering a variety of coursework
our main tracks or disciplines that we
tend to focus on currently
are forensic anthropology forensic
biology
forensic chemistry and forensic
psychology so we offer
these four mainstreams currently and
we're
introducing in the coming years of
forensic toxicology stream
for those who are interested in pursuing
toxicology in their future
forensic anthropology and forensic
biology are both offered at the graduate
level
in terms of research-specific masters
and doctoral theses
however that is faculty dependent based
on the 10-year stream faculty who are
currently in the program
within our program at utm we have the
option for students to complete
a specialist degree so where their focus
is primarily in one of the main tracks
that i just mentioned
or a major degree where they're
completing
a forensic science major coupled with
another science or math major
or minors and then we also now offer a
minor program
so for those who have an interest in
forensic science but don't want to
pursue that as their main focus
at university there is a minor program
where they can supplement
their current learning or discipline
with some forensics classes just so that
they become familiar and are engaged in
the forensic sciences
just to give you a quick visual
insight into our program we do try and
provide our students
at all levels a very interactive and
engaging
experience this has a lot of hands-on
components so with that
there have been many inherent challenges
this year
of note or the things that i would like
to focus on the most are the fact that
we really pride ourselves on having
engaging lab experiences so all of our
disciplines
in the upper years have actual lab
components where
students are getting forensic biology
forensic chemistry forensic anthropology
hands-on experience
in the lab so that they understand
how these disciplines then translate
into the real world or how these
skills and techniques that they're
learning in lab
translate into the positions they may
hold in the future
and because our staff and faculty come
from backgrounds that are very rich
in terms of forensic experience we're
able to bring a very strong and
comprehensive program to our students we
also offer
field school and we tend to focus in two
specific areas so we have the forensic
anthropology field school
where students literally go out into the
woods
and are sifting through a crime scene
and recovering human remains and going
through all of the processes that are
necessary in order to
establish the the biological sex
ancestry etc of the human remains and
process that case in a traditional way
that a forensic anthropologist would
process it
we also have our forensic ident field
school and that is led by a retired
constable from the forensic ident unit
of a police agency in canada where
students then go through how a
traditional law enforcement officer
would process
scenes and so our students really are
getting a lot of hands-on
and field-based experience within our
undergraduate program
it's really wonderful that we're able to
offer such a
strong and diverse program to our
students
but you can understand that in light of
covid a lot
of our programming has been challenged
by the lack of
availability to have students on campus
as well as ensuring our social
distancing measures
and everything else that has come along
with the challenges that the pandemic
has brought
so i just want to quickly go through the
canadian covid19 timeline i know that
on a global scale we're all well aware
of what's happened
but thinking more regionally for us and
how our program specifically has
been impacted i think it's just
important or
might be helpful for everyone who's
watching to understand what we did and
how we were able to respond
so thinking back to last year march 16th
obviously was a big turning point we had
our official closure
of the university all three campuses
all courses and all research labs were
immediately halted and switched
to online pro processes
what this meant was we were at the tail
end of our semester our semester ends in
early april
so we did encounter several obstacles
trying to immediately transition to an
online
environment but u of t put a halt
on everything for that two-week initial
window while we
navigated what the pandemic was going to
bring
of course as everyone is well aware
those
those closures were well extended past
the two-week period
so everything in the winter term for
2020 was then pushed online
including a final exam session
which was obviously a first for the
university
and faculty and staff really stepped up
to navigate what that would look like
and of course there were a lot of
challenges we encountered
increased amounts of plagiarism
we encountered increased amounts of
technical difficulties
time zone issues everything that you can
surely imagine
or experience yourself in terms of that
initial
reaction to the immediate closure
in may we launched our first remote only
term
for summer coursework all of the
research labs
and in-field or
practical components of our coursework
remained closed or
not offered so that was an incredibly
unique challenge
especially from the forensic science
program where we had students already
enrolled in those field schools
and we're gearing up for graduation
in june the university issued an
opportunity to
reopen labs with very very strict
criteria
so all labs were assessed in terms of
space and social distancing capabilities
how many individuals can we safely put
in our labs
what ppe is required to ensure that our
labs are operating safely
etc we were required to submit
comprehensive lab reopening plans in
terms of
who is required to be on campus so who
are our designated personnel
what students really needed to be on
campus
again trying to mitigate the risk for
everybody
and this was approved through our office
of the vice principal research
we also had very strict hours in terms
of our lab
operations so 7 am to 4 pm
to ensure that our facilities and
anybody that needed to be able to
respond in case of emergency was
available so no more of those late
nights in the lab
everything was quite restricted to those
daytime hours
so over this summer we saw a lot of lab
reopenings we saw a little bit of
movement back to campus from faculty in
terms of
maybe just wanting to get back in the
office to settle affairs that had been
lingering from
the spring term and then trying to
really
gear up and prep for the fall and
whatever that was going to look like
our fall term brought a hybrid learning
environment
meaning that the university did offer
critical courses that were required in
person hybrid courses where students had
the option to either
be at home or come into the classroom
and then those courses that were offered
completely online
why we had such a diversity of course
offerings was to cater to our students
so the university of toronto in general
brings in quite a few international
students we have a large international
student
body and with the restrictions for
travel and bringing students back with
the canadian government policies
i.e that 14-day mandatory quarantine it
was very difficult
to have students return and then be
forced to stay in their homes
and then be under the stay-at-home order
policies that exist in ontario
currently and then back in the fall so
we were trying to essentially create an
environment
that was conducive to all essential
coursework like i mentioned was allowed
to go forward in person if necessary
so those critical labs where students
required getting those hands-on skills
where something couldn't be provided in
a remote setting
moved ahead in person what this meant
was
a the faculty member had to be
comfortable b
the teaching assistants had to be
comfortable to come on campus
and see the students enrolled in the
course had to be comfortable to come on
campus
so of course you can understand that
this brought in and of itself
quite a few challenges in october
within the province of ontario where
toronto
is we had increased lockdown measures
and these varied but continued to cycle
through the end of the year
this made it increasingly challenging
and stressful for faculty and students
alike as we were constantly navigating
what policies were in place at the
government level
and then at the university level in
order to navigate our instruction
and our ability to complete the courses
moving into 2021 we again kept a hybrid
learning
environment offered through our winter
term
winter in canada obviously is quite cold
we have the increased challenges of
weather etc
and so here again faculty and students
alike were navigating
what was critical when did we have to be
on campus
so faculty in this instance moved more
towards the hybrid learning when
possible
and really reduced the number of
critical or essential courses that were
taught
on campus the government restrictions
have
increased in 2021 making it even more
difficult
to conduct experiments and be on campus
so in in that context it was very
helpful to have an increased number of
hybrid or
completely remote part of me completely
remote course
offerings for our students april again
brought a new stay-at-home order as our
cases continue to increase
and this again further
restricted our ability to conduct
experiments on campus
and to provide course offerings such as
the field schools to our students
going into the summer of 2021 so where
we are now
remote learning is currently dominating
due to the increased number of variant
cases
in the greater toronto area
okay so thinking back to spring and
summer 2020
i really want to focus on the pivot at u
of t
so thinking about forensic science
education and thinking about
all of the course offerings that we have
for our students we really had to
transition to this remote learning
environment
in order to serve the diversity of
students that we had
remembering that u of t has a very large
international student body we had a lot
of our students returning back to their
home provinces and home countries
and it was very important to us to
ensure that they were not derailed
from their academic trajectory and so
in light of that we ensured that we
could
offer the courses that they required but
in a remote setting
for example our forensic ethics course
using our very innovative and skilled
staff and faculty we were able to
develop this
train ride or roller coaster of ethics
where the student would essentially go
down the tracks and make ethical
decisions
that would lead them either further
along the path or
to a point of destruction and it allowed
them to essentially
test their ethical barometer per se
in a way that was engaging and that
integrated the course material
in a very um intellectually stimulating
way and so as we continue to move
forward in this online delivery we're
developing more and more tools
such as this ethical roller coaster to
challenge our students to think about
the course material
while still being engaged at the
computer
of course when it came to labs we didn't
have the ability to offer those
in-person placements so we moved to
online demos
and we cancelled our in-person
opportunities
over the summer what the online demos
typically entailed was
a youtube or a first person view of the
experiment so that students could
essentially visualize what they would be
doing with their hands
without actually carrying it out
themselves of course this brings
large challenges within the field of
forensic
science simply because you need to be
able to have those technical skills to
then walk
into a crime lab or to them walk into
another lab setting
so a little bit of challenge there in
terms of
really developing the skills for the
students however
we are doing the best we can to ensure
that they are getting
that experience or they're getting the
theory and
at best possible practical component of
the course
we of course had to abort or cancel a
lot of the ongoing projects
so thinking back to march 2020 a lot of
students were working on their capstone
projects
and those came to an abrupt end in terms
of the field
or in-person components what that meant
was
we wrapped up what we could and we made
do with the results that were already
tabulated
however those projects that were
potentially going to publication were
then put on hold until experiments could
be completed
that was of course a big disappointment
for both faculty
practitioners and students alike but i'm
hopeful
that we are going to get back on track
this year
the second point i want to bring up was
the forensic science research
collaborations and funding
so as i'm sure most people are aware we
had a big shift in terms
of funding allocation where most
funding was reallocated to covet 19
scientific research and that is
completely acceptable and understandable
in light of the severity of the pandemic
however that does
obviously impose severe challenges on
those not working in that area
additionally there were some constraints
on the collaborations with outside
agencies and labs
simply because everybody was navigating
and pivoting in their own direction
and maintaining some of those strong
collaborative
projects were were stressed or put on
hold a little bit
in terms of re-navigating what type of
in-person
exchange of either reagents or samples
or sample collection etc could be
conducted until things
improved
thinking to fall 2020 our new normal
we have navigated into this hybrid
system
of having a lot of remote only options
having some hybrid teachings and then
only those essential
in-person lab offerings are very
specific
in person necessary course requirements
the university of toronto continues to
maintain
this strong availability of remote
learning
that way it is accessible to our
international students
so we don't want to turn away our
international students in light of the
pandemic we want to be able to
assist them through this as much as is
possible
so then when the time is right we can
bring them back on campus
the hybrid model also works well for
international students because it allows
that flexibility for those who are local
to come on campus
but those who are far away to still
experience
and participate in the learning outcomes
of the courses
without having to be physically present
the only limitation
and this is specific to the forensic
science program
is the in-person component so those
courses like forensic biology or
forensic
chemistry that have the critical lab
components
or in forensic anthropology or forensic
ident
with the field schools international
students will not be able necessarily to
take those courses
or large amendments or accommodations
will be required
in order to ensure that our
international students can still
progress through our program
without being penalized simply because
they can't be on campus
so we are still navigating how that will
work
but of course that is a big challenge we
ultimately want our students who are
going through this program to develop
the technical and practical skills
necessary
to then go on into their future careers
but of course as the cases continue to
drop and as the restrictions around the
globe continue to
change and at times the restrictions
lesson
we are bringing more and more
international students back to campus
in as safe as is possible manner to get
them
back into the lab or to get them back
into the field school so they can wrap
up their programs
and move on
so again bringing us back to where we
are now
like i mentioned there is a lot of
fluctuation in terms
of government regulation and policy we
are
currently in a stay-at-home order within
the province of
ontario meaning that absolutely
nothing is proceeding on campus that is
not absolutely critical
and this involves lab operations as well
so that is creating a little bit more of
a restrictive
environment for our students but we have
been able to take this past year to
really navigate how to perfect or
improve our online delivery for everyone
involved
it also means a big shift in terms of
our forensic scientific projects
so both at the undergraduate and
graduate levels we have a change in
terms of how our projects are designed
so instead of doing sample collection
from individuals
we're approaching our projects in terms
of data mining or looking at previously
generated data
or repurposing some of our forensic data
that has been
applied to other projects into new
directions
so this is allowing us to alleviate some
of that tension
in terms of not having enough projects
for students or
feeling like we can't provide them with
an invaluable experience
but it does change the approach
or understanding of forensic concepts
when students aren't getting that in
person or in lab
experience
thinking quickly about the impacts on
both
undergraduates and graduate students
from the undergraduate perspective
the observed impacts i think are
multi-fold so we're seeing a change in
resilience
students are more flexible it seems with
last minute changes
but we are also seeing an increased
number of mental health
issues as a result of potential
isolation
and the various challenges of doing or
participating in online learning from
home
not everybody has the perfect setup not
everybody has the privacy
not everybody can commit the focus
necessary to truly engage in some of the
coursework that's being delivered
remotely
so of course we are seeing variable
levels of resilience
from our undergraduates we're also
seeing a shift in expectations
so for some students in vulnerable
households there is an expectation to
accommodate so that they do not have to
come to campus
and this is understandable but within
the forensic science program
it becomes challenging when we do
require an in-person component for some
of our courses
because not having them in the classroom
means that they will not develop those
practical skills that are required for
the field
but we also want to be respectful and
accommodate whatever it is
that they are for the challenges that
they're
encountering within the pandemic there's
also a demand or an increased
pressure for virtual over in-person
learning and again we're doing our best
to navigate what
is best for the program and best for our
students while still ensuring that they
are receiving those learning outcomes
are able to develop
the skills necessary from the courses
that we're offering
of course the frustration is real for
everybody
the constant flux in policies and
procedures both at the institutional and
government levels
are creating unnecessary stress for some
of our students
in terms of are we going to be in person
are we going to be remote
etc so we are seeing some variability
there
in terms of the overall mood in the
classroom
the lack of experience i think is the
most important
aspect to consider from the
undergraduate impact perspective
simply because if you're not getting the
technical skills how are you then
competitive to go into the job market
and that is something that of course
we're doing our best
to mitigate and we're doing our best to
accommodate in terms of developing
skills and providing invaluable research
opportunities
when the time and the restrictions
permit
and then of course going back to those
abandoned projects and publications
that brings in the frustration and the
shifted expectations
but we do have several projects that are
still incomplete
but then present the new opportunity
that when things restore or reopen
we'll have multiple people engaged in
these projects to wrap them up and get
quick publications out
the graduate impact is slightly
different obviously graduate students
have very tailored or specifically
focused projects
but we're seeing a big shift in
responsibility so in the past year we've
obviously
increased our demand for teaching
assistance or
online course offerings and that has
brought a need for the graduate students
to shift from their research into these
teaching roles
that's great in terms of developing that
teaching and leadership experience but
that does create an
impact on their overall research
timeline
and their focus as a graduate student
throughout their program
the shift in focus in terms of projects
has also changed so looking at more data
analysis
or remote opportunities rather than
in-person lab or sample collection based
projects
and again depending on the discipline
this can be
more challenging in some fields than
others
and the university restrictions in terms
of research activities
with regard to travel so if there are
collaborations with
agencies outside of the province or
outside of the country
there are quite severe research
restrictions currently in place
that prevent students from going to
collect samples or perform their
necessary venture field work
in order to collect that data so we are
seeing some challenges there
that have really been exacerbated over
the past year
finally we have this concept of delayed
timelines
and funding challenges so obviously
timelines are being skewed
with the shift to teaching and
responsibility
and then delays in their overall
research and then the funding associated
with that
so reallocation of funds again to covet
research and projects has created some
disparity in some disciplines especially
the forensic sciences in canada
and we also have this concept of loss of
grant support so students that are
currently funded
in light of the shifts away from
research
it does create these weird bottlenecks
in terms of how their funding will look
in the coming years if they have to
extend their timelines
so that is where we are right now we
have these funding challenges
in terms of how we're coordinating with
agencies how we're coordinating with our
grant funding
etc and what the long-term impacts of
those will be
are still quite unknown we have our
staffing challenges so we have
reduced or limited capacity staffing on
campus and in the lab
but we also have to increase our staff
for our virtual
and remote delivery safety is
always the number one concern at the
university of toronto
so we are being very respectful of the
space and time restrictions that are in
place both in the classroom and in the
lab
and there's currently no expectation for
any students
especially graduate students to be on
campus unless
critical experiments or operations are
required
and then finally as we can all imagine
there are impacts in terms of
productivity
we have this reallocation to a growing
number of emails and our inboxes
and a growing number of zoom meetings in
our calendars
that are taking away from our ability to
conduct research
further the pressure of constantly being
at the computer can be quite draining
and so we are seeing burnout quite a bit
sooner than we would typically expect if
students and faculty were at the bench
and that takes us to our next steps so
thinking about everything that i've
discussed in terms of the university of
toronto lens
when we think about forensic science
research and education
what does our future new normal look
like are we going to be making a lot of
adjusted timelines for completion and
are we going to be restructuring our
research focus
for graduate student projects or
undergraduate capstone projects etc
are we going to be moving towards a data
analysis
approach where you have very few people
in the lab generating as much data as
possible
that can then be disseminated outward or
how do we continue to move the field
forward
if we're really limiting our in-person
experiences
second are international students and
collaborators
how do we ensure that we can maintain
these relationships how are we still
satisfying our international students
when we have
strict restrictions in terms of bringing
our international students back
thinking simply about the united states
canada border
we have a lot of restrictions there in
terms
of flight travel in terms of land
crossings
and that can be very impeding in terms
of fostering relationships with our
collaborators and ensuring that we can
go and acquire our samples or be present
in each other's
labs to develop our research endeavors
and then finally just overall
collaborative nature
with outside agencies everybody is
adjusting to new policies and procedures
and ensuring that we
can still foster a very
conducive environment for research
collaboration
is going to be critical and so
navigating those next steps is going to
be interesting
but it seems that everybody wants to get
back to work
or a lot of people want to get back to
work and we're seeing a growing interest
in redeveloping those relationships
between
both the academic unit and our outside
collaborating agencies
obviously networking and collaborative
challenges from
the zoom perspective so wanting to get
back to those in-person conferences
there's a lot of burnout in terms of
virtual conference delivery
the doom of zoom i like to say um
we're navigating what that looks like
but of course we're seeing an
increase in hybrid delivery at least for
2021 but 2022 and 2023 conferences
seem to be moving to in-person
opportunities so that does bring
some optimism for that networking and
collaborative
future and then finally this concept of
establishing the virtual lab
so like i mentioned we have been using
tools like
gopro um and having that headset from
the first person view to
show students what it looks like to be
performing these experiments that
they're not getting
to do themselves and i like to think of
it more like the bill nye the science
guy
type of learning environment where
students can follow along the
experiments
and then apply the theoretical knowledge
that they've acquired in their courses
to really pull all of the concepts
together to ensure
that they've met all of the learning
objectives in the course
so then i want to turn it to you the
audience and really wonder
what are the institutional differences
that you see or that you've observed
between
your organization or institution and
what's happening here at the university
of toronto
as i can imagine on a global scale
there's quite a bit of variability
just in terms of institutional
regulations
and either provincial state or
at the national level regulations and
policies
as it relates to covid19 so what does
your teaching or learning
experience look like how has your
institution
pivoted or established a new normal for
forensic science education and research
primarily at the undergraduate level but
i would also love to hear what's
happening at the graduate level
and how student projects have pivoted in
that direction
how have your collaborations or
experiential learning opportunities been
restored
since all of these challenges have been
in place and now where are you going
from here
because i think that this is a great
opportunity as
the field of forensic science given that
we are so tight
knit to really share in our challenges
and obstacles and then
things that are working well now in
terms of just being able to help each
other out
and move forward in as positive and as
collaborative ways as possible so please
send me your feedback i would really
love to hear
what is working for you or what didn't
work for you
and what you're doing now as a
consequence of that
so thank you very much for listening i
really hope that you were able to take
something away from today's presentation
i would very much love to hear from you
so here is my contact information
my lab website if you're interested in
learning more specifically about what i
do
within the field of forensic genetics
and
again thank you for being here and have
a wonderful day